- michel field vous avez décidé d'écrire
ce livre pour occuper une année pas très
occupé à la télévision on vous a vue sur
arte pendant le festival de cannes on
vous voit sur tf6 dans bande à part j'ai
failli animé tomte shauna landes sur tf1
pour ça je me dis quand même expliqué à
nos amis ce que c'est un péché thaïlande
c'est de la télé réalité c'est à dire
qu'il ya des couples à savoir tourner la
norme marqué c'était moi je me disais si
je le fais ça une bonne promo pour le
suivre mais bon il la rupture la tiare
qui a des coupes qui sens sur une île et
on envoie des scot quoi sur des jeunes
filles très belle et des jeunes gens
très beau pour briser leur couple ça il
ya quatre coupes qui arrivent sur l'île
ils sont séparés les garçons d'un côté
des filles de l'autre pendant 13 jours
et chacun des groupes est assailli par
et demi une douzaine de célibataires par
des super nanas
mais je sais rien et tu as une sorte de
manipulation de la production jour après
jour pour juste faire les crises tout
c'est évidemment poussé à la tentation
comme mais vous avez sérieusement
envisagé de le faire
j'ai été tenté d'abord je voulais aller
y voir de près et puis et puis il ya
toujours le côté un peu provoc et
politiquement non correct qui faisait
que ça m'aurait peut-être amusé si je
n'avais pris conscience quand même en
regardant de près que c'était pas pour
moi voilà alors vous connaissez en ce
moment michel field de ce qu'on appelle
une petite traversée du désert vous le
dire je peux en parler parce que je suis
passé par là moi aussi et quelques il ya
quelques années
le problème c'est qu'on a toujours peur
dans ces cas-là d'avoir rejoint la
cohorte des ex animateur ou animatrice
qui disent depuis des années je vais
revenir qua non mais c est pire non
c'est ça c'est à dire c'est ça qui est
le pire et on se dit bon parce que si
c'est une femme finalement de boulot de
cycle et où on passe à autre chose bon
comme on a l'impression que c'est pas ça
du tout on dit bon ben voilà ça va durer
jupille ça va je suis pas non plus au
chômage à la démission mais voilà et
alors après on se dit mais c'est
horrible parce que finalement dans dix
ans dans 15 ans serait toujours en train
de lire brême est quand même il ya des
gens qui ont envie de jouer
donc faut essayer de faut essayer en
fait de se débrancher de ça et de faire
fructifier ces années un peu plus maigre
de de boulot de les faire fructifier
pour faire autre chose pour se
réalimenter pour ceux se
réapprovisionner donc voilà en résumé ça
vous fait chier quoi non sécher j'ai pas
tout compris
je pense que ça j'ai envie que ce que je
puisse dire oh là là c'était une
vachement bonne période les corses ce
sera un bon souvenir
ouais c'est pas encore tout à fait il ya
des gens depuis 15 ans qu'ils disent je
vais refaire de la télé normes et moi je
serai pas comme ça si vraiment je vois
que l'on veut plus je passe à autre
chose
je crois vraiment assez raisonnablement
c'est difficile oui mais pas tant que ça
finalement
comme vous comment vous l'aviez vécu
vous c'était beaucoup plus long que moi
c'est moi ça ne fait que commencer
ça a duré trois ans avait donc j'ai
encore deux ans à purger
à tout à l'heure je lis votre vrai nom
cfl choo c'était le nom de mon père mais
maintenant mon vrai nom i feel parce que
j'ai fait le changement mais evil
c'était le nom de résistance de mon père
il est vous est né à saint saturnin les
apps
ça semble assez incroyable comment vous
avez pu n'être là bas est en fait parce
que votre grand mère maternelle qui
s'appelait marianne prades était
comédienne de théâtre
un jour elle est en tournée dans la
région de de saint saturnin et le maire
de saint saturnin est tombé fou amoureux
d'elle c'était une rencontre
voilà coup de foudre par là entre
cellectis à une prédestination sur les
rangs couette peut-être et alors elle
fait un truc qui est incroyable parce
qu'on est dans les années 20 ou 30 qu'à
elle elle était mariée elle avait elle
avait deux enfants elle monte à paris à
l'arc son mari elle laisse son fils aîné
à son mari et elle descend s'installer
dans le midi avec ça tu lis donc ma
maman jacquotte way à jacqueline dit
jacobs voilà voilà
alors votre famille revient
régulièrement dans ce village et c'est
comme ça que vous naissez à saint
saturnin les apps en votre père lui
était ouvrier syndicaliste militant
communiste
oui faisait partie de ces de ces juifs
d'europe centrale qui avait quitté alors
lui l'autriche au moment de l'anschluss
il était venu en france pour participer
à la résistance
et puis voilà alors il travaillait votre
père chez jules sulitzer
tout à fait le père de paul loup
sulitzer remorque titan oui fameuse
remorque titans et entre eux c'est un
enjeu vacances à puisqu'entre c'est
assez marrant c'est toute la journée
c'est la lutte des classes parce
qu'évidemment n 1 qui était patron a
look était ouvrier et comme votre père
était très politisé évidemment toute la
journée ils les traités de sales
capitalistes vient comme une solidarité
entre eux et quand votre père a voulu
acheter un appartement dans le 16ème rue
ribera
c'est le père de sulitzer qui lui a
passé l'argent mis lui a dit tu me le
rendre à sûreté augmentation cet
amendement il a été bradée parce qu'elle
sait à l'époque de la reconstruction de
la politique mais de gaulle qui elle qui
favorise le logement donc la part qu'il
était en vente à un prix dérisoire pour
sa valeur mais en même temps
incommensurable pour mes parents et le
père sulitzer il dit à trois jours après
il dit à mon père mais je n'en dors plus
quoi il faut absolument je peux je m'en
voudrais toute ma vie pas t'avoir aidé à
acheter ce tabac et voilà donc c'était
pas du tout un bon exemple
deux classes patron piège des leaders
s'est mis à la tâche et son appart dans
le xvième c'était monstrueux mais voilà
et une belle morale de l'histoire estime
bros et moi quand j'étais gosse on était
encore assez pauvre en même temps mes
parents étaient proprio d'un appareil
16e qui est hallucinant par l'ironie de
l'histoire c'est que quand le père de
paul loup sulitzer moeurs lui les
spolier pelouse qui fait que avant de
faire fortune dans les porte-clés
l'objet de faire plein de boulot
terrible pour survivre vraiment pour
gagner sa vie et vous le fils de
l'ouvrier vous faites des études quoi
oui la version les destins qui est assez
extraordinaire aussi je trouve que
notable en tous les cas en 68 vous avez
14 ans vous êtes membre des comités
d'action lycéens
le mégaphone scotché la bouche j'ai été
exclu du lycée claude-bernard pour usage
intempestif de médiaphones merveilleux
comme bons souvenirs d'enfance moi je
voyage et élèves de 3e je dessinais des
marteaux défaut si sûr mais sur mes
cahiers de un jour ma mère avait pris
d'elle avait beaucoup de bon sens à elle
elle regarde ça et effaré dit mais
j'aimerais bien que tu dessines des
femmes à poil c'est pathologique de
marteau il faut six parties votre
premier passage remarqué à télévision
c'est en 1973 quand vous en prenez au
ministre de l'éducation nationale joseph
fontanet
et puis après vous devenez prof de philo
mais rapidement vous versez dans la
littérature érotique quand même un puits
a sévi vous avez écrit le passeur de
lesbos
c'est l'histoire et pas mal c'est une
charge à l'interview tout al'air
patricia c'est un homme dont l'épousé
part avec une femme quand il a un autre
de bouquins de michel field je les
conseille aux amateurs s'appelle
l'impasse de la nuit et c'est là où il
ya assez hard
ah ouais il ya un client qui rencontre
un travesti lui dit homme ou femme et
l'autre répond comme tu vois c'est
grandiose
ah oui les shows le chili patricia vous
regardez pas comme ça je tremble
dégagé en tous les cas c'est la suite de
ce bouquin que dechavanne vous invite à
ciel mon mardi où vous resterez
puisqu'après la dialyse après les
derniers aventuriers du sexe alors si
vous aviez une baguette magique la place
de quel animateur prendriez en ou non
mais j'ai visité le froid n'ont pas cité
le boulot ou trois noms et vous de jouer
je vais je viens de mettre en quatrième
est ce que vous voudriez la place de
guillaume durand de franz olivier
giesbert ou de marc olivier fogiel
non honnêtement honnêtement ce serait
non ce serait plutôt sur la sur le
créneau de guillaume durand n'est pas à
sa place à traiter moi j'écoute ce que
dit le ministre de la culture il faut
plus d'émissions cheval sur le service
public doit normalement il ya du boulot
pour tout le bourg c'est bon si vous
avez remarqué le créneau guy noël c'est
pas non plus un créneau où il ya
énormément de concurrence chez les
animateurs ben il faut savoir lire
écrire compter ça je suis pas content et
ils savent mais ils répliquent en moins
julie fléau le livre des rencontres